I have the best job in journalism not
just the best job at television
journalism the best job in journal the
and and the way I define best is that I
am free to practice the kind of
journalism I want to practice and so are
my colleagues at the NewsHour
we have nope no people looking over our
shoulders no PBS people no underwriter
people no any kind of people our
mistakes are our own if we don't want to
do a story on Paris Hilton we don't do a
story on Paris Hilton we don't want to
do a story on the OJ Simpson trial
we don't do a story on the OJ Simpson
Simpson trial we want to devote 20
minutes to global warming in Africa we
do 20 minutes on global warming and
Africa that may not be a good idea maybe
we should have done this or whatever but
we practice every day we sit we we are
we we don't have to worry about the the
outside you know journalism is in the
best circumstances
you're still going you're gonna you're
gonna make mistakes because news happens
it doesn't happen in neat and tidy
packages and sometimes you go on the air
6 o'clock Eastern Time the story's not
finished but you still have to go with
what you've got and you can correct it
the next day or whatever but but anytime
you introduce an outside influence you
increase it or increase the chances
you're going to be wrong we have no
outside influences now my job as the
executive editor of the program is that
I am the we what we call it internally
facetiously but not quite so physician
we have a have a Quaker monarchy in
other words we have a consensus system
where we where all of us work together
talk together about what we what we
think the news of the day is how we
should present it all that sort of stuff
but then in the final and the point is
we get but we can't agree then the
monarch takes over and I'm the monarch
and I ask some young man who is
doing a story for a magazine about all
of the TV journalists who are from Texas
and he was doing a piece why is this you
know rather was still there Schieffer of
course is still there and anyhow this
kid was taking my picture and he said
mr. Larry I said I've taken pictures of
all these guys now and they say they've
seen all uptight and you seem so relaxed
what's the difference I said the
difference is I am the boss and in a
journalism organization if you're not
the boss if you're not making these
final decisions you've waste all your
energy armwrestling what gives me hope
is also what concerns good things are
there's more and more information out
and available to everybody and there
ever has been it used to be three
television networks and us and your
local newspaper and that was it and you
could read the news magazines or
whatever but basically that's how people
got their news and it was all shared
news 90% of the people more than 90% of
the people that had given and at a at an
early evening time had watched one of
these three nightly news you know
hundley Brinkley Cronkite whatever and
so they all had the same they all got
the same information and then they
started their their arguments about it
afterward based on the same set of facts
now what's happened now is there's so
many different ways to get the
information in so many different formats
and some people get their information on
John Stewart which is made-up news
some people get their information on
blogs which is or is mostly opinionated
news very little original reporting goes
on there and there's cable news and
there's a radio shout shows there's all
kinds of things all kinds of vehicles
for getting information about things
that matter and that's a good thing
the bad thing is that there is sometimes
now the the first time somebody hears
about it story is when they hear the
joke first time they hear about a source
when they hear a strong shouted opinion
either on a blog or on a radio show or
whatever and the first prop the first
step which is the shared in other words
anybody can have any opinion they want
but but you can't have any set of facts
that you want and there should be a
platform of facts from which everything
else flows then if John Stewart wants to
make up fray and and and the fact of the
matter is the good news here is and the
good side of this is there is an
increasing there are increasing signs
that people get this they're sick of
having to to have their first
information come even if somebody from
the left or somebody in from the right
they only want to they usually only hear
from people it's possible now as you
know because of the what's available on
the internet whatever you can you could
hear and listen and read only from
people who agree with you 100% you would
never ever hear a contrasting view and
and you would know something you would
know something about a particular
subject but the people there are
evidence now that that the folks want
they want to a not a return because you
know I'm not talking about going back to
nightly news programs in the old sense
but they want a beginning they want to
in here is to be here here let us begin
with the news and you can get it on a
pink iPod with your name engraved on it
or you can get it at a newspaper sitting
in a sitting in front of the fireplace
or you can get it watching a television
program you can get it anywhere but but
in the beginning and every end and that
to me is both the good and the bad the
bad is that we haven't gotten there yet
and the good is that there are signs
that's going to there that that there
that that there is meaning and purpose
and a future I believe in reporting the
new street first
well the consumers bear a much bigger
responsibility now than they used to
because there's so many places to go and
there's so many they have to find these
places they have to if let's say that
that an ordinary person of any any
political persuasion any age here's a
wild opinion about something and let's
say it's about global warming and wait a
minute it didn't sound right to me you
know I think I agree with that but but
what are the facts what are the facts on
this there's got to be an automatic way
for that person to access the facts from
some vehicle it could be a news service
it could be a newspaper on an online
newspaper it could be anything but it
could be a way to go back if you have to
to get those to get those facts but
that's different you see I mean a
consumer that has to go and do that and
you have to you have to be a smart
newspaper reader after when you read a
newspaper you have to think hmm well is
there is there is there more to this or
is there there's somebody spending me on
there so you know you have to be very
you have to be very very careful but
that's okay you just have to when you
have because the good thing is that
everybody can be heard now there are all
kinds of citizen reporters there are all
kinds of this and that and whatever but
the consumer of the consumer of the news
has to really work harder than they've
ever had to before to get it all down
there's there are hopeful signs that
that there's going to be a we're going
to figure out a way to separate this
better the mechanics the technologies
make this possible
of course technology makes everything
cosmos still takes journalists to do it
in the beginning there is a journalist
the some journalist has to be has to go
to the courthouse or go to the White
House has to read the original document
has to get the original leak has to do
all of this and those are the folks that
need to be protected and need to be not
and and not be goosed up to goose up
stories and step over the line to juice
them up and give more opinion and all
that sort of stuff
I tell people all the time you know no
I'm not in the entertainment do you want
to be entertained go to the circus don't
watch the news hour and I don't care
whether I don't mind I'm not there to
make people laugh or cry or and you know
just give them the facts the best stock
possibly can and then then you other
people could take them and do anything
they want to with them but in the
beginning there must be the news I I
want to be known as somebody who
believed in and practiced encouraged and
set an example for civilized discourse
about things that matter that is my
simple goal in life fortunately I have
been given the opportunity and the
vehicle to do that which is the NewsHour
I believe that civilized discourse about
the hottest subjects in the world they
can be the most most crushing the most
burning the most controversial things
that you can imagine you can still have
civilized discourse you can still have
somebody over here saying you know this
is BA somebody's on the other side and
my job and I consider it my purpose is
to make sure that the people who are
doing the talking and doing the
disagreeing do it in a civilized way in
a way that does not necessarily question
the motives of every somebody who
disagrees if they do it they have to do
it on a civilized they can look at them
and do but anyhow I believe it's
civilized discourse I believe that
that's how you arrive through the
process they were it to arrive at your
own opinions if you do if you're not
sure about something and and you want
and and you want to know both sides or
all three sides or all four sides
because most cases there are more than
just wanted just to you what my purpose
and and what I want people to think
about when they think about me and what
we have done and what we created on our
program I want people think that's the
place I can go and hear all of the
opinions in a way that is is
understandable and will help me arrive
at my own opinion when it's all said and
done
and that's what I want